as you all know us sort of fraught times
right now tense times our country's
immigration policies are certainly in
the news including of course our
relationship with Mexico now there's
been a lot of talk from President Trump
about building a wall along the Mexican
border and imposing a stiff tariff on
Mexican goods this has got a lot of
people upset well I want to take things
in a more positive direction so as I've
said here's the plan
I'm gonna head down to Mexico City rent
a television studio and shoot an episode
of our show with the help of an all
Mexican staff crew guests and studio
audience we're calling it Conan Without
Borders made in Mexico
[Applause]
35 were looking for here it
tonight tonight I'm really excited and
proud to announce two of the guests who
appear on our made in Mexico shows one
is the one of the stars of rogue one a
Star Wars story diego luna is going to
get such a cool guy and another is the
former President of Mexico Vicente Fox
is going to be a guest on my show now
you may know Vicente Fox from his recent
tweets including this one from last
Friday I've made it clear Mexico is not
paying for that wall
I wonder what we're going to talk about
we're like goodwill ambassadors of
stupidity yeah no no no we're gonna go
down there we're gonna talk we're gonna
have a really good time we're gonna make
a lot of friends I think it's gonna be a
great show
Conan Without Borders made in Mexico
airs on Wednesday March 1st at 10:00
p.m. right here on TBS
[Music]
[Applause]
you